تدمر الحنه كلها من لم يجد سبيلا للفرار
من الاشتباكات قد يضطر للتعايش بين فصول
الموت على مضض هذا حال السودانيين
العالقين بين فكي النزاع
اقوال بعض شهود العيان لصحيفه نيويورك
تايمز الامريكيه تلمست شيئا من استراتيجيه
قوات الدعم السريع في السيطره على العاصمه
وذلك باعتبار الخرطوم معركه المواجهه
الاساسيه
يستخدمون فيها مواجهات الكر والفر
للاستيلاء على مواقع الجيش وبناء على
شهادات المدنيين فانهم رجحوا الا قائد
واضحا يملي الاوامر على قوات الدعم السريع
بل انهم يشنون هجمات بلا سابق تخطيط
مضيفين انها هي التي تحاول فرض سيطرتها
على الخرطوم وتتوغل في المناطق السكنيه
على عكس الجيش الذي يركز على نقاط الدخول
والخروج للمدن
وبحسب ما شوهد انتقلت قوات الدعم السريع
في الخرطوم مثلا الى اربعه مبانئ سكنيه في
منطقه واحده ومنها حولوا الساحه الى ميدان
للحرب ووفق روايه السودانيين تتركز هذه
القوات عندما مراكز التفتيش في مجموعه
تتكون من خمسه الى عشرين مقاتلا واحيانا
قد تصل الى 50 يعتمدون في وسائل النقل
جنودهم على مركبات تويوتا للدفع الرباعي
وشهدوا محملين بعده اسلحه من بينها
البازوكا
والكلاشنكوف والرشاشات وبنادق مضاده
للطائرات
وبينما تشتد الحرب ضراوه تنكؤ الهدن
جراحهم بفشلها يراقبون عن كثب ما الذي
سيجري وفي اي رحال سيحطون بها البقاء في
بؤر الهلاك ام الرحيل الى وجهه لم تكن
يوما ما في الحسبان اسراء الصغير العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات